tribune forsen de Davos
wai comme on dit guerre dîner de guerre par
le calendrier a toujours été et continuera
pour qu'ils soient les gens veulent toujours
manger toujours
[musique]
explosion eh bien, tout a commencé à tomber pour s'effondrer
les fenêtres s'effondrent, mais on va immédiatement au sous-sol ou
je suis resté assis là pendant vingt minutes et puis
progressivement commencé à sortir pour regarder
le spectacle est ici
retour au travail verre propre
pour le moment, ce n'est qu'un travail qui, par
le fait est nécessaire pour tout le monde
trace de nourriture puisque la plupart
établissements au moins au début de la guerre
Je me suis couvert pour arrêter mes actions mais je
J'avais l'impression que j'avais besoin de travailler
genre de qui sinon nous quelque chose comme
tel
c'est pourquoi je ne suis pas parti et j'ai décidé
du moins, je ne le fais pas et je le ferai
continue à travailler et à travailler
tu étais tu devais trouver un endroit où seulement où
obtenir mais ensuite trouvé des fournisseurs trouvés
tous ces huit venus d'autres villes ici